[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
Schirm
sie war ein ruhiges Mädchen
liebenswert
hilfsbereit so war Maria
nachdem sie mit dem Rad weggefahren war
kam sie abends nicht wieder und auch am
nächsten Morgen um 7 Uhr weil sie noch
nicht wieder zurück
unser erster Gedanke war dass sie einen
Unfall hatte aber was wenn es ein
Verbrechen war
es wäre einfach gut zu wissen was
passiert ist
dieser Gedanke lässt dich nicht mehr los
das ist ab wann der Tanten er hat vor
fast 30 Jahren seine Tochter Maria
verloren und wir sprechen heute darüber
was einen Cold Case ausmacht und in
welchen Abstufungen solche Fälle gelöst
werden denn beim Fall Maria van der
Santen hat es einen riesen Fortschritt
gegeben aber gelöst ist er immer noch
nicht ich bin Toni Heier und ich freue
mich dass ihr wieder dabei seid und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir hallo
wir gehen mit euch jetzt zurück in das
Jahr 1994 und wir gehen nach Pütten in
den Niederlanden die Stadt in der
Provinz Gelderland liegt etwa 70 km
südwestlich von Amsterdam im August 1994
ist Maria von der Xanten 22 Jahre alt
sie wohnt noch zu Hause auf Fotos sieht
man eine große schlanke Frau der
aktuelle Modetrends jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig wichtig sind Maria trägt ihr
langes dunkelblondes Haar in Stufen die
ein bisschen nach eighties aussehen sie
hat ein ehrliches Lächeln leicht
abstehende Ohren und eine kräftige
Mundpartie maria ist Einzelkind in einer
sehr religiösen Familie im Alter von 20
Jahren ist sie schon mal ausgezogen um
Sprachwissenschaften zu studieren ihr
Traum ist es später als
bibelübersetzerin zu arbeiten aber kurz
bevor das Studium losgeht machen Maria
gesundheitliche Probleme einen Strich
durch die Rechnung nach einem Sturz und
der Verletzung des Steißbeins sie
fürchterliche Schmerzen
zusätzlich raubt ihr eine
Viruserkrankung viel Lebensenergie Maria
zieht wieder nach Hause nach ein paar
Monaten Erholung macht sie neue Pläne
sie will im Hochsommer an einer
christlichen Jugendfreizeit in Spanien
teilnehmen danach ist ein Praktikum in
einer Kita geplant
der 6 August 1994 ist ein heißer
Sommertag Maria van der Xanten sagt
ihren Eltern gegen 13.30 dass sie eine
Radtour in der Umgebung von Pitten macht
zum Abendbrot will sie aber wieder da
sein
Maria schmiert sich ein paar Stullen und
fährt los und wie wir gerade am Anfang
von ihrem Vater gehört haben kommt Maria
aber nicht zum Abendbrot zurück und auch
nicht zum Frühstück die Eltern rufen
schon am Abend des 6 August bei der
Polizei an die Beamten Unternehmen
erstmal nichts schließlich ist Maria
eine erwachsene Frau erst vom nächsten
Morgen an wird sie als vermisst geführt
in diesem Sommer 1994 ist auf der Welt
durchaus eine Menge los auf dem Balkan
tobt der Bosnienkrieg in Ruanda gibt es
einen unfassbaren Völkermord in den USA
ist die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft zu
Ende gegangen aber Maria von der Xanten
macht nicht mal in den Niederlanden
richtig Schlagzeilen sie bleibt einfach
vermisst fast 30 Jahre lang Zeit für ein
bisschen Geschichte
[Musik]
die Möhnetalsperre gehört zu den größten
Talsperren in Deutschland und ist nach
der Seeoberfläche die größte in
Nordrhein-Westfalen im Naturpark
Arnsberger Wald zwischen Soest im Norden
und Arnsberg im Süden staut sie seit
1913 mit der Gewichtsstaumauer die
Flüsse Möhne und Hefe zum Möhnesee
erbaut wurde sie um die seit dem Ende
des 19 Jahrhunderts ständig wachsenden
Städte des Ruhrgebiets mit Wasser zu
versorgen im Zweiten Weltkrieg kommt es
hier zu einer Katastrophe die an den
heutigen Ukraine erinnert
die Briten bombardieren die Staumauer
und lösen eine gigantische Flutwelle aus
der Neheimer Pfarrer Josef Hellmann fast
die Geschehnisse so zusammen
in der Nacht vom 16 auf den 17 mai 1943
hörte man gegen 2 Uhr Schreier die
Möhnetalsperre ist getroffen dann folgte
ein furchtbares Rauschen so als wenn
eine Lokomotive ihre Dampf ablässt nur
in ganz gewaltigem Ausmaße immer
mächtiger wurde das Rauschen und schon
bald kamen Leute mit dem was sie gerade
fassen konnten aus ihren Häusern um in
die Berge zu heilen das Wasser war so
schnell über die einzelnen Wohnungen
gekommen dass die Leute die an der Möhne
wohnten zum großen Teil von den Fluten
fortgeführt worden das Wasser steht
schnell 10 12 Meter hoch und noch höher
die Briten wollten mit dem Angriff die
Rüstungsindustrie in Deutschland
Schwächen das ist nach Ansicht von
Historikern aber nur im ganz geringen
Umfang gelungen hauptsächlich starben
viele unschuldige Anna Schätzung zufolge
kamen 1.579 Menschen ums Leben darunter
über 1.000 Zwangsarbeiter und
Kriegsgefangene der Wiederaufbau der
Talsperre der begann noch in den
Kriegsjahren soweit der Blick jetzt in
die Geschichte aber auch in unserem
heutigen Fall spielt das Bauwerk eine
Rolle
am Sonntag dem 28 August 1994 entdeckt
ein Spaziergänger an der Ostseite der
Staumauer eine Leiche im Möhnesee sie
treibt kurz unter der Wasseroberfläche
er alarmiert die Rettungswacht in Soest
kurz darauf Rücken Polizei Feuerwehr und
DLRG am Fundort an sie bergen die
bereits etwas verwieste Leiche schon auf
den ersten Blick nehmen die Retter an
dass die junge Frau sich das Leben
genommen hat in dem Rucksack den sie
trägt befindet sich ein Stein die tote
trägt ein kurzärmliges rot-weiß
gestreiftes Hemd und eine kurze Jeans
die Obduktion ergibt wenig später dass
der Körper schon einige Wochen im Wasser
gelegen haben muss
bei der gestrigen Untersuchung der
Leiche fanden sich keine Spuren die auf
eine äußere Gewalteinwirkung schließen
lassen ein Verbrechen ist einwandfrei
auszuschließen vermeldet der
westfälische Anzeiger am 30 August 1994
in der vermisstenkartei der deutschen
Behörden findet sich damals kein Hinweis
auf die Frau es gibt auch auf gründliche
nachfragen in der Umgebung des Stausees
hin niemanden der etwas beobachtet hat
die unbekannte wird schließlich in einem
anonymen Grab der Gemeinde Möhnesee
beerdigt Angehörige können nicht
verständigt werden die Kosten der
Beisetzung trägt das Ordnungsamt
okay also an dieser Stelle halten wir
mal folgendes fest in den Niederlanden
gibt es seit dem 6 August 1994 einen
ungeklärten Vermisstenfall Maria van der
zanten verschwindet mit dem Fahrrad auf
eine Tour bei der sie nur ein paar
Stullen und etwas zu Trinken in einem
Rucksack dabei hat für die Polizei gibt
es ansonsten keine Spuren kein Handy zum
Orten keine DNA zum Abgleich keine
Leiche keine Zeugenaussagen nach allem
was man damals annehmen muss ging es
Maria gut sie hatte zwar eine leidvolle
Zeit hinter sich mit der
Rückenverletzung und der Erkrankung am
Pfeifferschen Drüsenfieber aber sie
hatte neue Pläne die Reise das Praktikum
falls sie unglücklich war bei ihren
Eltern unglücklich mit ihrem Leben dann
wusste das wohl keiner das niemand eine
Verbindung zum Leichenfund am Ende des
gleichen Monats sieht das ist im
Rückblick tragisch aber nicht wirklich
erstaunlich zwischen Marias Heimatort
Pitten und dem Müll nicht aussehen da
liegen ziemlich genau 240 km
internationale vermissten Parteien die
gibt es nicht und weder in den
Niederlanden noch in Nordrhein-Westfalen
wird in diesem Zusammenhang wegen eines
Verbrechens ermittelt es ziehen also
Jahrzehnte ins Land in denen Marias
Eltern in Gelderland keinen Frieden
finden nach dem Verschwinden ihrer
Tochter während drei Autostunden
entfernt eine anonym beerdigte Frau in
ihrem Grab liegt
aber weil Marias Vater nicht aufgibt
kommt schließlich doch noch Bewegung in
diese Geschichte die peter-erde Fries
Stiftung bietet ab wann der Xanten ihre
Hilfe an diese Stiftung ist übrigens
eigentlich eine eigene Episode dieses
Podcasts wert denn sie wurde nach dem
Journalisten benannt der am 15 juli 2021
in Amsterdam auf offener Straße
erschossen wurde
mutmaßlich wegen seiner Recherchen gegen
die Drogenmafia also diese Geschichte
die machen wir auch bald als Fall hier
Mirko weiter geht's die gemeinnützige
Stiftung untersucht alle denkbaren
Spuren im Fall Maria neu und so stößt
sie endlich auf einen möglichen
Zusammenhang mit dem Todesfall in der
Nähe von Soest diese Spur wird gerade
noch rechtzeitig entdeckt denn nach bei
30 Jahren würde das anonyme Grab in der
Gemeinde Möhnesee ablaufen und
eingeebnet werden
aber tatsächlich lässt sich ein
Zusammenhang der Fälle erstmal auch ohne
eine Öffnung des Sarges feststellen dass
die tote Frau im Grab Maria sein könnte
das zeigen nämlich ganz einfach die
Fingerabdrücke also die die nach Marias
verschwinden Empfinden von Gegenständen
genommen wurden und die von der
Namenlosen Wasserleiche von der
Staumauer so einfach ist der Beweis wenn
man erstmal auf den Zusammenhang kommt
und zu vermelden die Stiftung und
zahlreiche niederländische Medien im
Frühjahr 2023 den sensationellen
Durchbruch Maria von der Xanten wurde
gefunden
ihr Vater ab äußert sich in zahllosen
Interviews erleichtert wir sind
überwältigt von dieser Nachricht nach
fast 30 Jahren weiß ich endlich wo meine
Tochter ist es gibt noch viele Fragen
die wir hoffentlich in naher Zukunft mit
dem Cold Case Team und der Stiftung
beantwortet bekommen wir wollen diese
Nachricht erst einmal auf uns wirken
lassen
die sensationellen Nachrichten machen im
Mai 2023 die Runde wo genau Maria
beerdigt wurde soll erst einmal geheim
bleiben die Gemeinde Möhne sieht halt
mit dass sie erstmal keine öffentlichen
Auskünfte darüber gibt auf welchem
Friedhof sich das Grab von Maria von der
Xanten befindet wörtlich teilt eine
Sprecherin mit wir sind uns bewusst dass
das Interesse der Öffentlichkeit in
diesem Fall sehr groß ist aus
Pietätsgründen möchten wir aber der
Familie von Maria ermöglichen zunächst
in Ruhe am Grab Abschied zu nehmen
deshalb bitten wir im Sinne der
Angehörigen um Verständnis
also gelöst ist der Fall nicht aber was
passierte zwischen dem sechsten und 28
August 1994
Maria startet mittags in ihrer
Heimatstadt Bütten so etwas wie eine
Radtour bei Aufbruch ist es etwa 1:30
Uhr zum Abendbrot gegen 19 Uhr will sie
wieder bei ihren Eltern sein schminkt
man sich für diese paar Stunden
normalerweise extra Stullen oder wollte
Maria weiter weg wie ist sie von töten
nach möhnese gekommen eine Reise per
Fahrrad würde in etwa diese Stationen
enthalten
Emrich am Rhein Wesel Dortmund Unna
für die ziemlich genau 240 Kilometer
bräuchte man auf dem Fahrrad 12 Stunden
nonstop und ohne Übernachtung mit Pausen
und Hotel oder herbergsaufenthalten eher
zwei bis drei Tage auf der Strecke vom
flachen Gelderland in die Hügel
Westfalens sind außerdem 200 Meter
Höhenunterschied zu überwinden und
jemand hätte Maria doch wohl während
einer solche Reise sehen müssen zum
Beispiel in einem Hotel einem Kiosk oder
einer Tankstelle und was hätte diese
Reise gesollt also wollte Maria sich in
einem Gewässer fern der Heimat selbst
ertränken damit ihre Eltern nichts
mitbekommen oder führen all diese
Überlegungen in die Irre und Maria wurde
schon im Gelderland überfallen und
getötet dann wäre der ganze Weg zum
Möhnesee Teil der leichenbeseitigung
gewesen
ich weiß nicht Mirko könnte natürlich
auch eine Mischung aus beiden sein ich
finde aber jetzt zum Beispiel nur weil
sie sich Stullen schmiert es nicht
verdächtigt dass sie weiter weg wollte
aber wir wissen es nicht also scheinbar
war bei ihr ja nichts los also zumindest
wenn wie du es vorher gesagt hast hat es
niemand mitbekommen vielleicht wollte
sie aber doch weiter weg und dann
passierte auch etwas ungeplant ist ja
Toni das ist natürlich durchaus denkbar
ich gehe davon aus dass die Ermittler
sich damit beschäftigen und da noch mehr
Informationen ans Tageslicht bringen
aber jetzt wo alle Zusammenhänge offen
liegen wird sicherlich auch die Leiche
noch mal untersucht werden und wenn es
da etwas Neues gibt dann erfahrt ihr das
natürlich hier bei uns bei Tatort
Deutschland
haben wir mit dem Axel Springer Archiv
recherchiert so wie guten Artikeln aus
dem westfälischen und dem Soester
Anzeiger sowie einem Video der Peter
Erde friesstift
Stefan Netzeband Schnitt und Aufnahme
Toni Hayer brustproduktion durch die
workout-studios München wir danken euch
dass ihr heute mit dabei wart und sagen
bis zum nächsten mal euer Mirko und eure
Toni